il fait son come back dans les yvelines
le basketteur bamba cei 39 ans a rejoint
les rangs du chesnay versailles l'été
dernier après avoir joué à vendre en
nationale 2 son objectif relever un
dernier défi avec le club de r avant de
raccrocher ses baskets
je me suis dit que je vais venir à
versailles pour essayer de se dé
l'équipe à remonter parce qu'ils ont
très très bon projet que je voulais à
berrer au futur c'est plus qu'une plus
value ses limites un miracle que qui
viennent qui vient de jouer avec nous
étant donné qu'il était encore l'année
dernière en nationale 2 ans avant de
signer au chesnay versailles bamba cei a
connu une carrière riche international
sénégal avec une quinzaine de sélection
jouera également marqué l'histoire d'un
autre club yvelinois située à moins de
15 kilomètres le fc trappes saint
quentin en yvelines
le numéro 11 a rejoint la structure en
2002 à l'âge de 22 ans
une équipe familiale et que tout le
monde on s'entre aider les dirigeants
les joueurs tout le monde donc en fait
c'était une équipe un village le franco
sénégalais d'un mètre quatre-vingt
dix-huit réussir à emmener le club
trappistes en nationale une grâce à des
prestations de haute volée le basketteur
restera au total sept ans dans la
structure malgré les sollicitations
moi je suis un joueur qui est un peu
fidèle je pouvais aller jouer au dessus
et je pouvais aller tenter ma chance
ailleurs
mais ben je voulais grandir avec mais
qui me frappe est ce qu on a fait un
super nationale une aujourd'hui à
presque 40 ans l'intérieur veut avant
tout prendre du plaisir sur les parquets
et partager son expérience avec ses
coéquipiers du chesnay versailles
bamba s'improvise name parfois
entraîneur adjoint quand il le faut mais
je sors pas et de suie et tu prends
l'écran je vous parle empêcher sûr mais
si je vois des trucs que je suis obligé
de le parler nous donner les cancers je
pense qu'ils écoutent il le fait de
manière très respectueuse et il essaie
de rester toujours à sa place donc on en
a beaucoup discuté et c'est même moi qui
l'incitent à vient me voir et ne pas
hésiter à donner des conseils si besoin
bamba cei voudrait continuer à
transmettre son savoir après sa carrière
en l'entraînant des genoux en réalisant
des camps de basket caritatif avec son
association sauf hadji au sénégal mais
avant tout il veut continuer à jouer
pour emmener le chesnay-versailles le
plus haut possible